[Music]
what makes a Spartan a Spartan I mean
you don't just roll out of bed and start
battering grunts into oblivion poor
things it requires some serious
preparation some say Master Chief was
born with it
some say it's is extensive cybernetic
and genetic augmentations others say
it's probably the big hulking suit of
armor
now Master Chief suit is super cool and
can do a lot we obviously can't do all
of that in one suit right now but we are
working towards it and a lot of the
individual tech is actually pretty far
along the meow-meow law Mjolnir powered
assault armor system was developed in
parallel to the Spartan to program the
very project that trained up and spat
out the chief Mjolnir is an advanced
exoskeleton suit that improves the
strength speed and agility of its wearer
as well as being able to work in space
underwater and in toxic environments so
along with enhancing its wearers
physical abilities it also comes
complete with a layer of reactive metal
liquid crystal that houses an artificial
intelligence network naturally you can't
just pick up one of these bad boys from
the shops even in the Halo universe
Amelia will set you back about as much
as a small spaceship and that's roughly
what the US are spending in research in
order to build one for themselves
engineers from MIT the US Army and many
other assorted defense groups are
joining forces to create Talos the
tactical assault light operator suit
while it might not have all the
spacefaring bells and whistles that
Mjolnir houses the brief Fatalis was
that the battery-operated robotic
exoskeleton must be bulletproof
weaponized have the ability to monitor
the wearer's vitals as well as give them
exceptional strength and perception
abilities it's currently being prototype
so the specs aren't final but there's
some amazing tech being thrown around
like material containing a liquid dipped
in kevlar fabric that hardens under gun
fire there's the potential to use
hydraulics to increase speed and
strength and a heads-up display in the
helmet we've had rudimentary heads-up
display since the 1910s where reflector
sights were used in German fighter
aircraft since then they've been used in
the glass of military jets and in
firearm reticule
help the user line up their shots we've
had personal heads-up displays too while
Google glass may not have taken off it
did provide its users with the ability
to well not have to get their phone out
of their pocket every time they wanted
to do or look up something online place
potatoes and a banana
wow I'm busy right now hey I'll call you
later okay okay I love you I love you
though these displays haven't caught on
in our everyday lives they may find a
home in the military new helmet
prototypes don't just look remarkably
similar to halos headgear
but even contain a heads-up display to
give soldiers Maps mission updates and
the ability to communicate with squad
mates granted it's not at the stage
where it can tell you how many bullets
are in your clip or how much you're
bleeding but it's certainly a start
slowly bleeding to death in the middle
of Blood Gulch isn't ideal luckily in
the Halo universe if your energy shield
doesn't protect you from the worst of a
covenant or promethium battering your
Nyonya pumps your wounds full of bio
foam an expanding self-sealing medical
foam that regenerates tissue and kills
any nasty bacteria sounds too good to be
true but this kind of tech is already
out there quick clot combat gauze is
infused with a chemical kaolin which
accelerates the body's natural clotting
ability and is used by police medics and
even the military to dress wounds on the
battlefields it's even available to buy
on Amazon I just hope you never need it
why you can't just open up your armored
suit in the middle of a space flight to
dress your wounds we need something that
can be injected in a pinch
while that exists to Vetta gel was
released earlier this year for use on
animals the expanding foam can stop
bleeding and seal serious wounds within
just 15 seconds a version of us human
types is undergoing FDA approval so it
could be released as early as next year
the American military research agency
DARPA is also working on their own
version of payal foam the reaction of
two chemicals creates a phone that molds
to the shape of the patient's internal
organs stopping bleeding and stabilizing
them until they can be taken into
surgery where the hardened foam can then
be removed safely various new linear
models over the years have had some kind
of jetpack ability to allow Spartans to
dodge boost boost over objects or just
generally boost around
sadly talus is not planned to be
airborne but maybe it could be we've
lusted after jetpacks for years and if
you've got a spare 150,000 dollars lying
around in 2016 one could be yours the
Martin jetpack the world
first commercially-available jetpack can
fly for up to 30 minutes speech top
speeds of 74 km/h and heights of a
thousand meters it's being rolled out
for emergency services next year it with
a personal version prep to launch in
2017 so yeah maybe a bit too big and not
quite powerful enough for extended use
lifting a heavy armored suit but it's a
start
so despite halo and it's me only as
being a complete work of fiction a lot
of the tech is weirdly close to becoming
a reality
like Cortana she could be everyone's AI
companion now hi I'm Cortana what other
kinds of Halo tech would you like to see
in our real lives be sure to let me know
in the comment section below thanks for
watching this episode of reality check
don't forget you can find me on Twitter
at Lucy James games and I'll see you
next time
[Music]